You are liars, and you shouldn't be here. You don't believe in
anything you say, and you try to hurt people who call you out
on your >> But Destiny and Dan, unfortunately in my opinion,
they're acting like they have a head shot against Jstar Kleeman
and schizophrenic community members, and I don't think they do.
>> You've literally doxxed multiple people. You unbelievable,
embarrassing
What the [__] is wrong with you?
Can you please just explain the >> Okay, so there is a
clipping Discord that I'm a part of, okay? I will ask for links
to stuff. Uh I will suggest clips to people. I'll retweet other
people's clips. Right? Basically, they're trying to post like
cut up logs with absent any context as if this is like an evil
doxxing server. Destiny wants this to go and flow into his greater
narrative that I'm running like a cabal that's been working against
him, that hates him, and wants to undermine everything he's ever
>> Shamoon the Conjuror is caught using doxxing tools to
unmask anonymous ex-users in the Snark Discord. Leaked logs show
discussion on using doxxing tools, tracking username history,
and trying to pressure anonymous accounts into revealing personal
information before the conversation moved to private channels.
Anyone know how to gay up them into revealing more info? Run
the doxx tool. What's the doxx tool exactly? >> Well, well,
well, Destiny and Epstein desperately trying to smear me as some
kind of doxxer or something with some redacted thing of a public
only fans person. Novaruu is another friend of Tektone who lives
in uh Texas, which is public on their Twitter. So, you redacted
that to make it look like I was doxxing their location, but it's
public on their Twitter. You slimy piece of >> Is is >> Okay,
I'm looking at this. >> So, you redacted the the username
that's redacted was in these logs. >> Username in these
logs, you redacted it and said it was different to the doxxing
username. It's not, is it? >> Uh Okay, yeah, the Steam
name here is the same as that one. Yes. >> Okay. So, you
were or lying earlier, weren't you Dan? >> Uh, my bad.
They they re-entered the same username twice to get email. Like
if you want, as I said before I >> So they were using a
single username. I mean one username was posted there. They didn't
post the doxxing tool. They didn't run the doxxing tool. >> They did
post the doxxing tool. They post what? There two of them, Sherlock
and Holark Ever. >> They did not post Holark Ever. They
mentioned it. >> Yes, they did. Um, oh, sorry, they mentioned
it. Okay. >> Also, my question What are you accusing Shimoda
of? Answer my question now. >> I'm trying to find the actual
real life identity of an anonymous Twitter >> And so you
say this is a lie. >> And then being able to send it off
to someone else. >> to find or trying to dox? Trying to
find or trying to dox? >> Oh, sorry, trying to dox the
identity off of a username to send it off to >> why is
So you think Shimoda Shimoda is trying to publish it? That's
what you think? For the purpose of harassment. >> Well,
I mean, uh, could be. I have no [__] idea. He said
he hated the person, right? >> Nice one, you So you've
no idea. Nice >> You sneaky little
>> With that being said, I think we're on to the Connor
stuff now. Finally, we're on our way. We can head on over to
it. The Connor stuff.
>> The The issue is the you are finding people that you
perceive to be as not on your team on this whatever this is and
then you are leveraging every single asset and weapon you can
to hunt this person down and then to try to split them off by
engaging in like multiple levels of harassment to to break them
away from whatever person you're >> Okay, this is more
of a tangible allegation. That's what he's saying we're doing
I guess. That's what he's saying this Discord is doing. >> Going
after. That's really the issue. Um, everybody has their own feelings
on [__] Personally, I wouldn't fix it on the doxxing
part. I don't give a [__] about the doxxing part.
The issue is the this hyper fixated um, hyper
>> This what you're highlighting right now is not that
even a little bit.
What you're highlighting right now is these two being having
an investment in the Techtone story and trying to help Pink understand
that there's somebody harassing her who is directly involved
with Techtone. That's not what's happening with the thing you're
circling is not that.
He's like going back to what he thinks me and Queen Man are doing
to him, right? And trying to say this is an example of that.
It's not. It's not even remotely close to that. You talking about,
dog?
How How is anybody getting broken off? What the [__]
are you talking about,
>> top-down mediated harassment campaign against people.
This is wild. It's
But what about the argument that you're responding to doxing
with doxing? For that, you have to have either I have to be there
to have the conversation or you need to have like a strong person
>> I have to be there to Don't argue this at all, guys.
Don't argue this at all. Don't Don't Guys, don't go and argue
that I should be able to dox people. I It looks embarrassing.
>> My first question is always like, "Oh my god, did you
hear that A did this crazy [__] to B?" My first question
is always like, "Oh [__] what did B do? Why did A
do that? What was going on there, you know?" Because A >> Yeah.
So, just be very accurate about what A did and then say you doxed
in response to it. But the problem is you couldn't do that. That's
why you had to lie about it. That's why you had to say that Queen
Man and I were involved in Kiwi Farms and we were like getting
you guys doxed and swatted and all of this [__] That's
why you consistently did this because if you actually just said
what we did, you would look deranged because you are
>> Okay, A can be a horrible, terrible, malicious actor
or B could have had it coming. Really depends on what's going
on, you know? Yeah. But the But But the the frustrating thing,
too, is that um these actors like Connor or Wick or whatever,
I don't know if they just don't understand or they don't care,
whatever. But the people that I'm arguing with do do understand
it and they will make those arguments um for ethical doxing,
right? Which Which is what happens later on in this video is
when they realize like, "Okay, well, hold on. Is all doxing bad?"
Well, if it's a person that's harassing >> The thing we've
been saying this whole time, the thing I brought up with Erudite
was I need a specific allegation I can respond to. Otherwise,
you're just leaning into this and saying I'm doxing people and
opening me up to being harassed or being doxed in response. You
are You are basically putting a massive target on me. I've been
asking for what is the specific allegation? What did I
Instead of subtly supporting Destiny's baseless accusa- accusations,
you directly accuse me publicly or privately of what you're implying
here. So, you can actually defend myself. There is no allegation.
I have not been alleged to have done anything specific.
And they're saying it was okay to dox me. There is no evidence
for anything they've alleged in terms of my conduct. They've
created like They've tried to make it so I'm like Schrödinger's
doxxer. I'm both a doxxer and not a doxxer until you can prove
other way until you can observe. But, Destiny won't let anyone
observe.
And so, somehow, and I know I know how, it's just the clout,
it's just the money, it's just the capability of like leeching
off of his audience. That's the only reason people aren't like,
"Yeah, we should just look in the box." What's in the box, man?
What's in the box?
But, they don't want to look in the box. And I think it's I I
think at this point, to me to be honest with you,
the the piling on, the perpetuating the narratives without being
willing to look in the box or say that it has to be considered
false. Destiny is a liar until he can show anything he said.
The refusal to do that is
disqualifying for politics for all these people. They are too
disingenuous. They are too self-involved. They are liars and
they will warp their own opinions or feelings on the world for
money and clout over anything. They have disqualified themselves
from being political commentators. You have to look at whatever
the evidence is and say you are deranged or not. When he refuses
to show you, when he says, "Oh, I'll show you after my case."
you. And if this was happening to any of you, I would be standing
up against it. I would be. you.
Listen, it was I I was too much of a when it was Sunday, okay?
I was too much of a but even I said, "Hey, that was Never do
that again. Hey, what the You guys You You be shocked that people
are going to call you a doxxing community. If Dan's going to
come on my stream and say the name of some Hassan editor cuz
he hates him. And if you're going to come on my stream and try
to drop President Sunday's name, you cannot be upset or confused
when people call you a doxing community.
And that was that wasn't strong enough. I should have taken a
stronger stance than that.
But none of these people could even do that, it seems like. None
of these people would say anything along these lines at all.
Very sad. >> And Pinky Chu, who's a victim of assault,
and we need to get his information in order to help out Pinky
Chu, right? Isn't it good Wow. Wow, it's okay. Maybe it is. Maybe
there's a time and a place for where having an identification
of a person is actually like a worthwhile thing, you know? So,
you know, if you ask >> So, Destiny went beyond just having
If Destiny had looked up this information and kept it in his
back pocket in case he wanted to file a subpoena later, nobody
would be calling him a doxter,
That's not doxing. You found that information, you hired a private
eye to go and look into these people, you found out where they
lived, and you wanted to serve them with papers.
No wrongdoing has occurred. Now you publish it online to [__]
with them explicitly. You post it on websites that are meant
to facilitate real-life harm on people.
Now you're deranged. Now you're out of your mind.
Why are we Why would we pretend >> I ask people, why have
you guys doxxed Destiny? Why do you guys doxx these people? You
know, what is your goal for doing it? On their side, it's because
he said something I don't like, or he was mean to somebody I
don't like, or that I do like, or he has a political opinion
I just I don't even know actually what their I don't know what
the rationals they give for any of these people are. I have to
go in and look at >> Um listen,
for the for the Cybo one, I think it's like total I think he's
obviously lying, right? >> For people that I've been involved
in with this with, it was because they were spam copy-pasting
uh insanely disgusting
attacks against the girl that I was debating from a >> So,
the story here is he now hangs out in a Discord with Kelly and
the person the other person who is spamming these
This is like totally disingenuous. He's obviously like lying
that this is his line. He hangs out with those people now. He's
in a Discord with those people. Why would everybody who actually
disagreed on this, who said, "No, no, no, no, no. This is wrong."
Why would we be held responsible? By the way, Leilani, the girl
he was dating, messaged me directly and said, "Thank you for
saying that that was not okay. I really appreciate you standing
up for me." That's what she said to me.
So, the idea that this was a And by the way, I said, "Hey, if
you could like chill him out on the doxing stuff, in in return,
I would really appreciate that cuz I'm pretty concerned about
it." >> from another thread that it wasn't her thread,
but it was somebody else's thread for a person she dated. And
then they were spamming those attacks into Justiccal's Discord
via Kelly Jean oftentimes. And then they were using that to attack
uh my girlfriend at the time because they thought that it was
disgusting that she hadn't publicly disavowed me and left me.
>> Yeah, Kelly Kelly was saying this and I was repeatedly
saying, "That's not okay. That's not Show me any evidence of
other people jumping on these attacks and going with that except
for Kelly and I think Shelby. Right? I think it was Everybody
else in the Discord was like, "This is disgusting. Off." I on
the stream said, "This is disgusting. Off."
No, you don't do collateral attacks. You don't do that. You don't
know what that person's opinion is. You don't attack them for
not disavowing Destiny. Unless they basically have given you
some standard, unless she came out and said something like, "Oh,
if this comes out to be true, I disavow."
Right? Unless she did that, you have no reason to do it. >> So,
the issue with people like Connor and Wick is they're too to
see the difference between these scenarios. They're like, "Well,
it's still all the same." It's really not. If you're not a >> You
don't care about the Kelly thing. You don't even care about Lena.
Like it's you're obviously lying when you say you care about
Lena. You're just obviously full of
>> It's really not the same at all. But like they they
just don't understand. So, these are like >> He hung out
on a stream with Kelly, by the way, like a month ago, 2 months
ago. He was just hanging out on a stream with her. Was he going
the whole time? It's so disgusting that you attacked my girlfriend
like this. Did he do that or maybe I missed it. Maybe I missed
him going like you're a totally disgusting, disingenuous piece
of [__] Kelly, I hate you. I hate you. Does he He
justifies coming after me, the person who was against that, who
said that was bad, who had a whole discord who said that was
bad? And then he hangs out with Kelly after that. Very weird.
>> Again, it's always the worst when you have the people
in the center that you have to go through to to demonstrate the
insanity of the other side because they play this like, "Well,
I think that it's all bad." And it's like, "Okay, yeah, me too.
It'd be cool if nobody was doing this kind of behavior." But
that's It's not a little
>> I mean, it sounds bad, but I need more context to understand
what a gabs is getting at. Yes, I'd like to hear a
as to, you know, what what is what is he looking to get out of
it and what is a gabs exactly? >> Can you spin an Can you
spin an example where this would be except >> What is a
gabs? I honestly don't >> Gabs is the internet slang version
of astroturfing. So, gabs would be I know that Connor is streaming
today. I really want Connor to hate Destiny. So, I'm going to
make an account called
fourbrofesterhitsquadDGG and I'm going to go into Connor's
chat and I'm going to type things like Don't you think that
Don't you think that Destiny was right when he said that monogamous
relationships suck and that's why you got divorced? Like wasn't
Destiny It'll be like stuff like that to where the content creator
will see it, he associates it with DGG. >> So, hold on.
Is this like >> Wait, what? >> Wait, what?
Hold on. Hold on.
>> This is the internet slang version of astroturfing.
So, gabs would be I know that Connor is streaming today. I really
want Connor to hate Destiny. So, I'm going to make an account
called um
and I'm going to go into Connor's chat and I'm going to type
things like um Don't you think that uh Don't you think that Destiny
was right when he said that monogamous relationships suck and
that's why you got divorced? Like wasn't Destiny It'll be like
stuff >> Did this get coordinated somewhere?
This just sounds weird like I would just be like that's weird.
That's weirdo behavior. Why you doing that?
What is he just inventing stuff? Is he creative writing? >> What
are we doing, man? like that. To where the content creator will
see it, he associates it with DGG or with me, and then they get
these opinions over time. This is what Gaps is. This is astroturfing.
It's creating other accounts to go in and mislead people about
where you're from, and then to kind of uh subtly inject your
ideas or your you know, whatever you want that community's kind
of understanding of a thing to be. That's what Gaps are. Try
to absolutely know what Gaps is. Every single person that's operating
in this space for the past decade absolutely knows what Gaps
is. Everybody does. He's had stream titles in the past that know
what Gaps is. That's why everyone should be required to be identified
on the internet and to relink their SSN every week to all ask
for I mean, I honestly think that's true. If you make it your
whole life online to harass and abuse other people, I think it's
worth it to know who you are. I think your name should be tied
to that. I don't think you should be allowed to engage in that
type of behavior forever and then be able to walk away from it
because you're bored. I don't think so. So like when Esports
Batman wants to tie his like reputation as a lawyer into making
claims about the legality of You don't actually believe this.
If you believe this, you wouldn't let actual lawyers comment
to your under
By the way, I totally don't want that. I don't want that. That
would be disgusting. But he's obviously lying here. of my court
case or whatever, then I think it's I think it's okay for people
to want to know, like, well, who is this person? Like, that should
be I think it's okay to want to know. It's not okay to publish
it because you want to harass them away from the space. That
is what's not okay, you lying disingenuous worm.
tied to your professional reputation. You're staking your professional
reputation on it on your legal conclusions or your legal analysis.
So, why wouldn't people have a right to know who you are, right?
I I The idea that you could um you know, credential yourself
in such a way and then run away from who you are, that is that's
insane to me.
You Where did he run away to?
There's no running away. You just wanted to harass the guy away.
That's the only goal here.
If you thought he was doing something improper, you could have
without doxxing, again, this is the problem. There is a thing
happening here where Destiny tries to say, well, I had to dox
because the public had a right to know his name. One, no, and
two, if he was doing something improper, you could have found
his identity and reported him in a way that's to say, hey, I
think what this guy is doing is improper.
You could have done that.
But you didn't do that. You just published it because you were
trying to harass them. It's just like when he when he talks about
like why he went after me or anyone else. He could have if he
He said, by the way, what he said originally as well was he wanted
to serve me with a lawsuit. He's never attempted to serve me
with a lawsuit,
He said he wanted to do that. If he actually wanted to do that,
he would not have published any information he found, right?
He would have just served a
You are lying. You're just lying, man. Um so, he just made that
clip made it clear it isn't the standard, it's the fact that
the analysis is not in his favor. Exactly, yes. It's but it's
not even that, Destin Suggs. I truly believe he's just such a
small, petty, vindictive person that realistically his dox targets
aren't people who are just discussing his case. They're not people
the people with the worst opinions of him. They're just people
who he used to know who don't like him anymore.
That's that's the most offense That's why he picked eSports Batman
and Wicked
That's why those were the people he went after. It's cuz Supreme's
By the way, he posted a screenshot of what he said he was doxing
Supreme for. It's something like this guy's just like kind of
a sad, weird little man that is like crashing out. That's essentially
what he doxed Supreme for. That's it. He posted a screenshot
of like what set him off when he was going to do it, and it's
literally like, uh Desi, he just seems like a really sad person
who's lonely and just wants his friends to like pay attention
to him, and it just feels a little weird to me. Like it's it's
really sad watching what's
Is it just accurate accurate cutting analysis from somebody he
used to respect? Hurts him more than anything in the world. >> Hey
Desti, but can't they argue that this is what they were trying
to do? >> I don't understand what you I don't know what
you mean.
uh you can you can say that if you want, but I um I mean like
there's a fact of the matter at the end of the day that we can
talk about, right? Like I don't I don't obsessively
um stalk and harass >> Dude, there's I'm not even going
to film on it. Just Just if any of you are ever in DGG, the number
of times he has laughed his ass off, the number of times he has
totally discredited Hasan or Vaush for saying that his community
and him stalk them, right? And he says, "That's cuz you just
don't want to deal with the criticism. That's cuz you don't want
to deal I'm just watching your public your public streams. I'm
just watching your public content." And he's totally flipped
on this 180 completely.
It's so
embarrassing, dude.
Everything he once preached, he's turned against. He is just
a whiny [__] who doesn't have any principles, who's
totally falling apart. >> I and go over the personal lives
of all these people every single like I don't do it. The whole
reason why
um the whole reason why Jessical even became popular as a streamer
is because I was so disinterested in all drama content that I
just off-shored all of it to the after hours to Jessical's stream
cuz I had I had no desire to do this type of like super inter-
>> You watch the stream constantly. You're just lying right
now. You watch the stream You engage in it constantly. What are
you saying? What do you talk about, >> personal drama.
It just wasn't It just wasn't part of my content anymore. And
it really took >> Right when I first started, he came in
and was like fighting with the women posting. We had like not
safe for work channel. There were women women posting nudes in
that Discord. People who had relationships with him, by the way.
And like it was a whole massive drama. That was within 3 months
of the community
What do we talk about, man?
[__] we talking about?
>> He just wanted a fake separation. He didn't want to
not have drama. He just wanted this fake separation so that he
could push it away from him and pretend that it wasn't there
because he wanted to do he wanted the political clout without
dropping all the drama. And let's be real, like the fact that
people will like get really invested in the content and he's
kind of like a pool of fans to [__] That's what he
didn't want to get rid of, right? He wanted the pool of fans
to [__] but also to be a serious political creator.
And now he's posting weird screenshots of himself in a bed at
3:00 a.m. to me and a bunch of people are like quote tweeting
that and going, "Dude, what the [__] is wrong with
this That's where he's at now, okay? Very different very different
place in life at this point. >> Um what would you say to
the people defending you who are concerned about being doxed
for tributably for defending your doxing? I mean like it sucks,
but I mean that's what these people do. I mean they they will
dox anybody around me. Like they already doxed they were doxing
random chatters of mine a year ago to try to get people to um
disassociate >> any evidence that this is tied to me. Again,
we're here again. We're here So when he says, "Oh no, these guys
are like deranged." I'm just looking for any evidence, man. Any
evidence at all.
There just hasn't been any evidence. No evidence shown that I
have anything to do with that and I can cover your content. That's
the way this all works. I'm just covering your stream. Stop seething
about it. >> disassociate with my community, yeah. Force
you to do anything, okay? We I there you don't have to If you
don't want to give an answer maybe 2 hours and 17 minutes.
>> Is it fro- another case of frolicking going on?
I feel like this term helps explain a lot of behavior, especially
that of big content creators who bully and harass smaller streamers.
Narcissistic rage is a sudden intense outburst of anger or aggressive
behavior or cold weaponized silence displayed by someone with
narcissistic traits. It is triggered by a narcissistic injury,
a perceived slight, criticism, or boundary that threatens their
fragile ego and shatters their illusion of superiority.
Understanding this phenomenon involves recognizing its roots,
manifestations, and strategies for protection. The
frolicker POV frolicker POV right now. Root causes triggering
shame. It stems from an underlying deep-seated fear of being
found out flawed
found out flawed or inadequate. Then a narcissistic injury, anything
that challenges their grandiosity or sense of entitlement acts
as a severe blow to their art superficial self-image. Loss of
control, when they can no longer manipulate a situation or get
the consistent admiration they feel entitled to, they lash out
as a defense mechanism to regain dominance.
Common manifestation manifestations, explosive outbursts, loud,
disproportionate, and often terrifying fits of rage involving
screaming, threats, and aggressive gestures. Passive-aggression,
simmering
There's like a rumor, and this is totally rumor by the way, it's
not I I I have no way to prove it, but I have
that when Dessie Molina had like their final argument, that he
picked up her phone and like threw it at the wall.
Now, is that is that even something that I would say like is
outside of any relationship? No, but it's just funny. It's just
like a funny thing.
I bet you he didn't even put a hole in THE DRYWALL, MAN. IT'S
LIKE Trump throwing the tendies at the wall, you know? Similar
levels of reportable of reporting reliability,
you know, Trump throwing the tendies at the wall, Dessie throwing
the phone at the wall, very similar. I I can't say I believe
it happened, okay? I Well,
certainly nothing in his character would lead me to believe that
it didn't
but I just I think it's like um somebody told me this happened,
I have no way to prove it or know.
Passive-aggression, simmering resentment, deliberate neglect,
cutting sarcasm, or weaponized silent treatment to control and
punish others. Blame-shifting, the refusal to take responsibility,
often resulting them accusing you of causing their anger.
Oh my god! Oh my god! Blame-shifting, like you got into a ranged
war with schizos on Kiwi Farms cuz you were a loser with no actual
like attachment to any other person, and so you just fought with
somebody on a forum, right? And then, after it came out that
you were a disgusting freak, right? That you were a consent-violating
pervert, after that came out, you decided that I was to blame
for it. Oh my god! It explains all of it!
And now my my tendrils have shifted from just snarking Destiny
to ruining all of American politics. The top three threats to
the American political way of life are, in order, Trump, then
the Maga movement, then J Stalk, okay? These are the big three.
The big three that we are terrified of that will lead to the
destruction of democracy.
Truly, truly, truly.
I'm just glad I beat on Hasan. It's very funny. We're We're back
to this. Let's Let's check it out. >> And uh >> What
the >> They use doxing tools, I think they call it. They're
basically like open-source intelligence gathering tools in order
to try to find information on online account that
Is Destiny going to like that that Connor corrected open-source
intelligence gathering tools? >> as harassing Pink Pinkachu.
>> And I don't even think that was true. I think it was
just people that they were beefing with.
>> Is that they uh they planned on if they actually found
out a personal identifying information they'd out. Like let's
say it was Pinkachu or it was a Pinkachu community member, they
were going to pass it on to Pinkachu or a lawyer or whatever
so she could defend herself legally from these people who were
digitally harassing her, right? >> And so she boo in the
camera rolls. There's also this like thing of like um I just
I hate describing >> This is not like proven out by the
logs >> That's just common sense things, bro. This actually
drives me crazy. It's just like the least favorite part of streaming
where some of the stuff that people are saying is just weird.
I feel like there's like a there's a There's a moment in in like
a TV show or a movie. Actually, it happened in To Kill a Mockingbird.
Um am I misremembering this or is Atticus Finch kind of like
this like lanky, tall, has glasses, like seems kind of like a
meek man, and that's just kind of how everybody kind of views
him. And then there was a I believe people thought it was a rabid
dog, and then he is like handed a rifle and he goes like, you
know, sights up murder mode, like one shot obliterates this dog,
and like the children are like, "Whoa, Dad's on some wild shit."
Did this happen or am I making this up, right?
>> I don't know what the [__] he's talking
about, man. >> I feel like sometimes there are these moments
in There are these moments in movies or TV shows where like something
is happening, and then one of the characters is like, "Oh, [__]
It looks like the zombies or somebody's about to do this. Like,
let me take care of it." And they do some crazy [__]
And everybody else around is like, "Wait a second. What the [__]
How did you know that shit?" For Connor to like breeze over and
maybe he won't breeze over it, okay? But for Connor to breeze
over, "Oh, well, so there's a person that was harassing Pinkachu.
So, in their Discord, these guys went ahead and they grabbed
an OSINT tool that's used to fully >> Oh, I see what he's
arguing. This is like He's arguing that these guys are like um
they're kind of
Jason Bourne, right? That they've got these tools, this training.
Of course, they know to go to these tools cuz they want to use
these tools. Now, this is of course completely defeated by just
a little bit of thinking cuz then if if they could just think
a little bit, why aren't they basically being like, "Isn't this
website this one? And like kind of way it costs money, but like
could we look something up here?" Huh. So, they know everything
about the tools, but they don't have subscriptions to them or
use them frequently enough that they could just message somebody
directly. They're like pondering.
Isn't that kind of just defeated by the logs outright? That they
use these tools often. They didn't even have a subscription.
It costs money. They don't even have a subscription.
Come on, man. >> dox people including caches of leaked
passwords and dark web or online ordinary internet databases
uh because they were trying to protect Pikachu. That's like >> But
they didn't ask for that information. They weren't looking for
>> I think that most people would say uh how the [__]
do they know about this tool? Like the obvious assumption would
be, "Oh, well, these guys are definitely like people that have
done this before." This is this is probably like an ordinary
part of what they do, right? Like if you were to if you were
to go into a community that doesn't do this and you were to suggest
something like this, most of the people would be like, "Oh, um
that's kind of weird or I've never used this product or know
what this is or like isn't this a lot or what should we do?"
But like when it's like, "Oh, hey guys, we'll use this tool."
It's like, "Okay, yeah, I'll forward it to whatever. We'll figure
it out." Right? It's obvious that this is ordinary behavior in
the community. I hate that I even have to say this cuz this is
just such an obvious thing that any human being would piece together
>> They're defending their honor with
>> Yeah, again, it's just sort of defeated by the fact
that they had to ask. They might be aware of it and they are
researchers, right? They are like Again, this is like standard
in commentary research. Should they be talking about it in that
place? No, but it's absolutely standard in commentary
>> with this argument saying like, "Yeah, we might have
engaged in an attempt to dox or PI operation or whatever the
[__] you want to call it, but we were doing so uh
for noble reason and we did not have the intention of publishing
it, which is technically the definition of doxing." But the DG
DG people are saying like, "Oh, you're still trying to find somebody's
PI." I'm kind of lost. Why do they give a [__] about
TechTone of all people? Because I think TechTone I don't even
remember why. Maybe it was cuz Dan was talking to TechTone. TechTone
is like part of the enemy team. So, >> The enemy team being
people who have done really like bad basically like crimes, you
know, exposed minors to get a very young age, right? If they
they've they've done these kinds of bad things and the majority
of the content or very large portion of the content is Azan is
That's the core of the killer
document, right? But also for Shamoo, he just identified that
Tectone was harmful like a little ahead of the curve. And for
Nikondros, he just didn't like Nux. Oh, what's up, Iron Fists?
Thank you for the 500 kicks. With With Nikondros and Shamoo,
they had their own interest in the that content before they were
like interacted with us. It was because the content was so well
done that we started talking to them and hanging out with them.
So, like the reason they ended up in the community is not because
we all share the goal of with Destiny. It's hey, these guys are
like good. They do good work. They exposed some wrongdoing over
here. Let's let's talk to those guys. Let's see what they want
to do. Let's see what they're You guys got any thoughts on on
how this should be presented? You guys got any thoughts on how
you'd like phrase this argument?
It's a meeting of the minds
that they don't like cuz those minds don't have any investment
in them.
We evaluate Destiny or Ethan or Tectone purely on their utility
to the world and we find all of these people lacking.
Okay? You are a negative. You are a net negative not just to
the world but to the content creation space more specifically.
Do I care that you're a net negative to the world? Not
But you are harmful to the content creation space. You are oppressive.
You are liars and you shouldn't be here. You don't believe in
anything you say and you try to hurt people who call you out
in your you. So, they will like go after people and I don't even
I think I literally think it was just because Dan talked to him
once on stream or something. I don't I don't remember. It was
something stupid like this so that like they had that feeling
about him that he was like part of the enemy team, which is technically
the definition of doxing. But the DG DG was saying like, "Oh,
you're still trying to find somebody's PII." And that's what
we were accusing him of the entire time. Oh, was Oh, oh, The
connection actually I think that's probably right. It wasn't
the connection from Dan to Teckton. It was because Teckton was
attacking Hasan. That's probably what actually correct. Sorry.
These people are affiliated with Chud Logic, they're affiliated
with schizo communities, they're affiliated with Queen Man and
Jstark and all that kind of stuff. So, what Destiny and Dan what
they have accused Jstark, Queen Man, and schizo communities members
of the commentary community of doing is harassing them digitally
by finding their personal identifiable information and then publishing
it to the internet so their families can be harassed so they
can be harassed and be doxxed and swatted. So, they say, "Ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha." We have caught you in a private Discord using
the tools that we know that you used. But what Jstark, Queen
Man, and other community members are saying is you didn't catch
us specific- You didn't catch us specifically.
You have no evidence of us specifically engaging in the bad behavior.
And in retaliation, you have engaged in this bad behavior yourself
against us despite not having evidence against us specifically.
So, the way that I would say it >> Also, the bad behavior
from Destiny came before this Discord even existed is the
So, it's like people who we didn't hang out with when the Destiny
stuff went down that that Destiny blamed me and Queen Man for
like being these crazy and unhinged stalkers. It's people engaging
in it who weren't a part of our communities. Like they Or at
least I'm trying to think TheKandros might have been kind of
around and cuz he was a Harmful Opinions chatter and Harmful
Opinions had a lot of overlap with Chud Logic. So, TheKandros
might have been like spicy chat at some point. But he wasn't
in like our communities. I didn't talk to TheKandros for quite
a while. You know, maybe I might have commented on a Nux video.
Definitely by the time he got to the Muta Har Engineer stuff,
I would say. >> it is, if I was to try to take somebody's
personal identifiable information and publish it to the internet
so that they could be harassed and or send it to a friend or
use an alt in order to get somebody digitally harassed, I would
want to know 100% proof proof positive that the person that I
was attacking was guilty of the crime. I would not do this like
scorched earth counterinsurgency
everybody who's resisting us that Destiny and Dan are doing.
I think it's immoral. I think it's unethical.
>> See, like it's annoying because like Connor is in there's
some other part of his brain that's engaged right now, but especially
if he was ever a cop, like this is absolutely
this is absolutely how you function in the world. If you walk
into a what a >> They talked about like people getting
off for murder. He literally says that he's had like dead to
rights info that doesn't meet the muster for proof. Right? But
also, there's no tactic that Destiny and Dan aren't using to
prove this. Like you're not operating in the same world. You're
not even trying to prove things to a reasonable doubt. I'm saying
show me the evidence of me participating in this stuff ever.
That's what I'm saying.
You know what I mean?
It's totally crazy.
>> spider whatever the [__] If you walk into
some house and there's like two
that are you know, probably drugs on the table and there's like
four other people standing in the you know, like the next room.
Conner would never be like, well, I see we have two narcotics
users here and four of their friends must have stumbled into
here and I'm sure they have no idea what's going on. You would
never ever ever ever ever make that assumption, right? That's
just never going to be the case. If you stumble into a spot and
there's some going on and there's a bunch of other people around
that are all friends with them that aren't directly involved
with the [__] You assume that they're all if they're
not all in involved in the [__] they all know about
it and then it's generally like accepted in that community, you
>> I also think that while there may not be fire, like
we're not seeing the fire, there is smoke here. Effectively,
that the commentary community is they use OSINT tools, but we've
known this for years. We just have specific evidence of specific
the commentary community members using open source intelligence
>> Dude, Conner just made the point. Is he going to engage
with that? That people in the commentary community use those
tools and they have done for a long time to do research and they
handle this kind of PII all the time. All of the people who made
Turkey Tom's videos, all the people who've made basically anybody
who does long-term research on anything will know about these
tools, will do these tools or sorry, use these tools rather,
not do the tools, Jesus. There's no no response to that that
you've totally hung out with people who do this. The decor way
this is evaluated is how safe
you know, risk-averse are you with letting that information get
exposed? How well do you protect the person whose information
you might have to look into these things, right? That's That's
the thing. And obviously the Cantros Shamoo have been very careful
about that as commentary YouTubers. >> Anyways, so I think
we understand the dynamic. The but Destiny and Dan unfortunately
in my opinion they're acting like they have a head shot against
J Soc Queenman and schizophrenic community members and I don't
think they do. I think they have smoke. They don't have fire.
And so I want to see fire. I want to see J Soc or Queenman interacting
with doxing information. I want to see schizophrenic community
members engaging with doxing information. I want to see you know,
I want to see more substantive evidence that the specific people
that they're going off against are engaged in doxing and PII
gay ops. >> So like the issue with this particular ask
is that like it's like saying like I'm not going to arrest um
I'm not going to go after
I don't know the names of the the big drug people. I don't know,
some mafia boss until I see him selling crack on the street or
whatever. And it's like the people at the top top top don't have
to do that. But they know that it's happening. They allow it
to happen under their watch. And then all of the information
that filters to >> So show that we know it's happening.
We allow it to happen under our watch. Hold on. Hold on.
Show that. Show that we know that it's happening. We allow it
to happen under our watch, right? Like you could couldn't you
just show that? You can't say, well, these people somebody like
lit a bag of [__] on fire, put it outside my door,
and then go, well, because that happened and this guy This guy's
always hated me. He he like spit at me once at a football game.
He's always hated me. It's like a guy from your church community,
right? He's always hated me. And I know it was him. And the fact
that he hates me and that he says that he hates me to other people
proves that he put the [__] on my door. No, it doesn't.
No, it doesn't.
>> videos, tweets, or whatever else as a result of that
information, then they go on to directly amplify while claiming,
well, I ban that behavior in my community in the public-facing
one like in his just goes like Discord public facing server,
um and then Hassan will amplify that behavior on top of it, right?
>> Hassan's amplifying doxxing now?
Hassan's amplifying doxxing apparently? Let me Let me listen
to this again. >> it's happening. They allow it to happen
under their watch. >> We know that it's happening. They
allow it to happen under their watch. >> the information
that filters down into videos, tweets, or whatever else. >> And
all of the information that filter the the doxxing information,
right? There was like doxxing information that came through.
What's the information that filters down into tweets and
What is this? >> As a result of that information
>> As a result of we we we had to dox we had to find somebody's
docs to get information. I'm trying to think of like what example
this could come from. Man, like cuz I I think Shoe has done some
some FOIA requests, right? To find stuff for his videos. But
like that's not I didn't help Shoe make his video.
Like I I wasn't involved, right? I didn't even I don't even know
if I knew about Shoe before I saw the TechTone
Like if I said it would be loosely interacting and maybe spicy
at some point in the past. I'm like trying to think of how I
can even make this make sense. I'm like trying to help him prove
his theory. But I can't I literally can't. I'm trying. >> Then
they go on to directly amplify. >> That's the funny thing,
Gummy Verse.
After the leaks they amplified their attacks. I don't even know
if they amplified their attacks, Gummy Verse. I'm not even joking.
The doxxing is way more before the leaks happened. The the like
doxxing stuff that's all way before or like a huge chunk of it
is way before. Like the stuff that he was mad about, the stuff
that Erudite referred to, that's before the the what do you call
the lawsuit. Maybe not before the leaks, I can't remember. It's
somewhere around but I think Erudite has to complain about getting
swatted between November and
But in any case
that's like when the harassment was ramping up, right? It was
not it was not
something to do with me. I was still, you know, he was still
coming on my stream and
>> claiming, "Well, I ban that behavior in my community
in the public-facing one like in his just goes like Discord public-facing
server." Um and then Hassan will amplify that behavior on top
of it, right?
>> No, you're arguing he would amplify the stuff that flows
down into the videos. But then you have to argue what that is.
You do have to prove it. You can't just keep gish galloping saying
different [__] Well, and so they find information.
They'll find like they'll doc somebody and then and then but
they won't publish anything. And then they'll use whatever information
they found to find something out and then that'll filter down
into videos and then Hassan will publish that. It's like, "Okay,
what is the harm that happened there? What is the harm that happened?"
>> And so I mean that's like a vibe thing. Don't really
have uh don't really have like the fire, but obviously I feel
like we have the smoke. So, this is only a small part of the
leak, too. Yep, I agree with that. So, but that's where reason
riffs. I want the bigger parts of the leak, right? So, if there's
something that's more substantive that actually does point to
schizophrenic community members engaged in P operations, then
I I want to see that. Connor, we agreed 2 months ago that the
only thing that would convince you is DMs. Yeah, pretty much.
Pretty much. But but hold on hold on though. Fire out, I want
to amend that statement though. It's not that I don't think it's
happening. I'm not that naive. But if you're going to convict
someone or digitally harass someone, >> See, like this
is like weird. Are we using the Are we using like the criminal
conviction standard of beyond a reasonable doubt here? Cuz you
don't apply this standard to any other spot of your life, right?
>> Then I think you need solid proof positive evidence.
>> You You need some solid evidence. Yeah, you absolutely
need some solid evidence if you're going to start doxxing people.
Yes. Yep. Yep. Yep, you do. You need to >> I'll be like,
"You don't. You don't need that for anything." I don't know any
YouTube video that functions on a like a beyond a reasonable
doubt basis. >> To dox people you do. If you're just going
to say, "Well, these people did something mean to me and now
I'm doxxing them." And literally all you have is
uh you or Connor just total like schizophrenic slob. Nothing.
You got nothing to put out. Yeah, you No, you need something.
You need You need to show it to people. You at least need to
be willing to show it to people. Come on, man.
>> This is your This is your criminal conviction standard
of proof necessary for the state to deprive you of constitutionally
due freedom. It's like this is like for a good reason the highest
Like this is such a high standard of proof that we expect that
some guilty people who have actually committed a crime will walk
free. That's how high that standard of proof is. That's such
a weird thing to call for in like these online communities. >> I
shouldn't get to digitally harass you through guilt by association.
Right? >> There's also another thing, too, that these guys
never seem to consider where they say like well, this is enough
for digital harass my I would say like all of this stuff is perpetuated
in a one-sided manner. There's no world where if JustAGuy and
esports Batman and all these and Wicked Supreme and all these
[__] weirdo losers, if they like stop talking about
me, where on stream every day we're like oh guys, did you see
what happened here? Oh guys, did you see this? Oh, did you see
that they got into a fight here? Blah blah Like why? We would
just wouldn't We would just stop talking about them, right? And
even I wouldn't go a step further.
I'm not even saying that these people should have to like They're
never allowed to comment on me or anything ever anymore. It's
like if they want to do like political things or whatever else
or talk about how my political things are Or even if they want
to talk about my I guess like my >> No, I will talk about
your public-facing content and your conduct. Anything that's
in the public, I'll talk about.
No, you Oh, here's actually what you could talk about and I won't
dox you. You. No, you. >> Um drama for um whatever my >> It's
not one-sided, Litigious Gamer. He doesn't Like basically this
guy is like Harvey Weinstein. If Harvey Weinstein came up and
went, "I didn't even do anything. I wasn't even talking about
this. Why is the New York Times talking about my allegations?
THIS IS HARASSMENT."
NO.
NO. Or TMZ. Let's say TMZ cuz it'd be more tabloid. That's more
on brand for us, okay?
We'd be covering like little angles and stuff. I'm sorry. You
don't get to start doxing people. Crazy. >> [__]
court case or whatever else, then fine, talk about whatever you
want. But it's the fact that you have become like my political
things are Or even if they want to talk about my I guess like
drama for
whatever my core case or whatever else then fine. >> Wait,
are we inventing a new standard because that's I swear you just
doxxed e-sports Batman on the him discussing your court case.
You just doxxed him on that. >> Fine, talk about whatever
you want. But it's the fact that you have become like an active
participant in all of it that is just so far beyond the pale.
>> An active participant in all of it. And
evidence, please.
>> It's just like so far beyond the pale. And all of that
is one-sided.
>> No, it's not. You've literally doxxed multiple people.
You unbelievable
What the is wrong with you? Um actually taking it to the next
level is just ALL ONE-SIDED. BY YOU.
IT IS ALL ONE-SIDED. BY YOU. WE'RE NOT DOING THAT AT ALL.
WHAT THE IS THIS GUY talking about? >> Real serious post
manifest will be your clean break with all the drama, right?
Well, probably not. It like my core case ending will be helpful
for sure. Um and then in my manifesto there are at least a few
people that I'm going to nuke for sure. And in an ideal world,
yeah, I wouldn't want to associate with any of this but the reality
is like these people will always be functioning like this unless
something changes
until like a strong it have there has to be a strong center left
thing that is built that can withstand this and I just don't
know
Liberalism might not BE STRONG ENOUGH TO PROTECT me from the
outcome from the the consequences of my actions. We need a stronger
liberal liberal movement that can protect me from leaking multiple
videos of people without their consent. That we need a stronger
liberal movement that can do this.
I can't but uh Holy
I can't say what needs to be said right now. I'm on Twitch.
But holy hell. Holy hell.
Dude. Liberals just might not be strong enough to get through
me might violating multiple women's consent.
Liberals liberalism just might not be strong enough to make it
through this. They can make it It could make it through Trump,
but it can't make it through my crimes.
>> Bro, liberalism don't need you, little Shut up. >> Well, who
else is even capable of it? Maybe Hutch, I think he's getting
there. >> He's unironically leaning into it.
I am the only one who could stop MAGA. I AM THE I AM THE ONLY
ONE WHO COULD stop MAGA. You thought you could stop MAGA without
me, but you need Trump grabbed them by the That was critical.
YOU DIDN'T REALIZE IT WAS CRITICAL. I grabbed them by the by
electronic means. I publish with women without their consent.
I record people. It's interactions without their consent. And
you didn't realize you needed that, did you, Democrats? But you
do, dude. Actually, this is insane,
Is it totally insane?
I should stop getting shocked by this. It shouldn't be shocking
to me anymore, should it? I feel like it shouldn't be shocking
at all. Which might be there. >> Um I I don't know. I don't
know who else. Yeah. >> So, 100 Argentinians are going
to write a joke. >> But like what I'm talking about would
have to be in the order of like multiple massive content creators
that are aware of this and can like very easily dispel it or
talk about it and be done with it, rather than like shy away
from it, you know, in a terrified manner. >> I also would
like those content creators to talk about this. Yep, I would.
I would also like those content creators to talk about it. I
would like them all to get informed. I I think we can all agree
I would be psyched if some people wanted to come in and get informed
on I'd be happy for them to talk to Destiny, and then I'll talk
to them. And we could all have >> like a back and forth
on this. Yep. >> But Hutch can seem to view things uh like
Connor and Wick. I don't think Hutch ever both sides of the internet
drama stuff. He might I don't Hutch doesn't both sides anything.
>> Hutch just doesn't know. Hutch is too egotistical. Hutch
is egotistical enough
he would rather ally with Destiny than learn the truth, right?
That's That's who Hutch is. >> We just disagree on how
far the Democratic Party needs to go coming into office. Hutch
is probably one of the only other strong lib creators who's like,
"We probably shouldn't be sucking up to tankies all the time.
They want to destroy our movement. We probably shouldn't be um
giving a pass to people who are engaged in like the crazy weird
Democratic Party assassination [__] that like the
far left like he's like the only guy that does that I think almost.
Hey, thank you for the five gifted two months over. Hutch Hutch
is almost ready to save democracy, guys, because he just repeats
what I say one-to-one. HUTCH IS ALMOST STRONG enough to save
democracy.
He just doesn't have the last thing that I have that he doesn't,
the
the uncontrollable desire to violate women's consent.
That's the only thing Hutch is missing. If we could get Hutch
to truly turn to the dark side, we need his Anakin moment where
he cuts down all the Padawan.
It's Hutch being given multiple videos that he knows are not
consented to to be distributed and him tweeting them. Okay, that's
his Anakin moment. Once Hutch is there, he'll be strong enough
to defeat MAGA.
I actually changed my opinion on this one, Destiny. he docks
somebody merely for discussing his case and threatened to dock
anybody in my Discord. If a much larger creator is explicitly
threatening my friends and community, should I just allow this?
breaking YouTube TOS in the process. If you're threatening us
and not just threatening us, but following through on the threats,
doxing threats, taking things out of the digital realm and putting
them into the real life realm. Intentionally, knowingly.
Now, remember,
the only thing that I'm asking for these people to leave me the
[__] alone is to stop stalking, A-logging, and harassing
every single person in my personal life. You don't care about
them. When those people got docked, you didn't even want to let
them know. It's a totally fake thing. When those people got docked,
you didn't care to even let them know. Now, he may have been
convinced to let them
by somebody else. I have no idea if he if he on in July of or
on July 24th, I have no idea if he went and talked to these people,
okay?
But he didn't care to go notify them
By the way, as soon as Erudite stopped being like super cringe
all the time, as soon as she stopped being like the most cringeworthy
human being ever, I stopped reacting to her. Like if she's just
fighting Republicans, I I don't react to that content.
It's just It's weird. It's just weird stuff, man. >> That's
the only request I have. Can you just like not like if you want
to talk [__] about my or whatever.
I showed the clips of what this was. I've not been going after
like I react to people. That's it. I just react, man. I just
react. That's it. >> I political takes if you want to talk
[__] about my or whatever. If you my whatever, fine.
But it's the >> This is not the standard.
This is not the standard. This is not what you started doxxing
for. >> You're relentless.
>> That's why he has to Oh, I see. This is a new narrative
shift, isn't it? So, it's not that it's not that you can't watch
his stuff. It's Or sorry, it's not It's not that. It's that Kelly
Jean was talking [__] about his girlfriend. Okay,
I totally What Why am I the target if that's the problem?
I wasn't I wasn't talking [__] about your girlfriend.
I was actually yelling at the person who's trying to talk [__]
about your girlfriend. That's what I was doing. I was saying,
"Don't focus on other people. Don't go and attack other
That's That's me. That's what I've been saying. Who's confused?